sir bob neal thanks very much indeed for
speaking to us why do you think it's
time for boris johnson to go
well because i promise at the beginning
to my constituents is that i would weigh
up uh the details the contents of the
sugro report and listen to
any explanations which the prime
minister gave i've done that and i've
reflected on them and i'm afraid i
didn't regard the explanations as being
credible there was a course of conduct
that took place here in number 10
downstream the pattern of behavior um
over a number of months which clearly
breached the rules
and which
was offensive i think to many many
people who are doing the right thing and
trying to stick by the rules and we
can't have a situation where those who
are making the rules are not adhering to
themselves when they expect everybody
else to do so so that and that in turn
had led me uh to listen very carefully
to my constituents who have been saying
i'm afraid for some weeks many of them
traditional conservative voters
particularly when i was canvassing
during the local council elections but
they were saying i'm sorry we've lost
faith in the prime minister we have
faith in 2019 but we lost faith in him
now and we're losing trust in the
conservative party under his leadership
and because that trust has been
undermined i don't believe sadly that
the prime minister he is able to rebuild
it and therefore we need to move on and
find a new leader for the conservative
party
uh what is it specifically about his
explanations you didn't find credible
this time around because he he has
repeated the same explanation since day
one really uh uh what why now
well i think when we look at it we
started off um with uh a an explanation
that
no rules were broken well we now know
that they were
then we've found an explanation that
well we didn't believe they were being
broken i don't accept that anyone could
reasonably have thought that it was in
the rules to have a leaving party that
seems to be the suggestion i don't think
most people regard that as being
credible
i know quite a number of people who left
work who changed jobs during the
lockdown they didn't have leaving
parties they perhaps
said farewells on zoom or they postponed
the get-togethers until such times as
the restrictions were lifted so that
doesn't i think hold water and i don't
accept that there could have been this
course of conduct without the prime
minister having been aware at least of a
great deal of what was happening if not
every single thing so that's where i'm
left in terms of my assessment of the
credibility and that in turn leads me to
my assessment that the trust that sadly
has been lost it's a shame because he's
a man of very real talents in many ways
and i'm nothing against him personally
we've always gone on well but once the
trust is lost and that not only damages
the conservative party but it actually
damages politics as a whole and that's
it even more significant
uh and you mentioned there that your
constituents also have lost faith in
this prime minister you mentioned you
know he's a talented man a lot of people
uh fond of his character but clearly a
lot of your constituents telling you
enough is enough
and that's it that that's the reading
that i've taken from this now i speak
only for myself uh every mp has to come
to their own conclusions on that but
these are people who have been the
bedrock of conservative support uh for
years and when they say that
they're usually not far off the money
i'm sorry to say
what's the mood then in your party
tonight we've had a resignation earlier
today we've had two letters of no
confidence uh being sent um
including your own of course
what are other mps telling you you're a
much respected member of your party i'm
certain you've spoken to others
well i'm no doubt that a number of my
colleagues are very concerned at the
situation as i am but i haven't acted in
concert with anyone i came to this
decision on my own
and
according to my own assessment of the
situation so not be acting in concert
with anyone i'm not part of any campaign
uh either against anyone or for anyone
i've just taken my own decision i'm
sure that there are others
that feel
equally troubled but how they
choose to act thereafter what steps they
take
that i respect is that it's their right
to decide on
do you think we could expect more
letters of
no confidence
well uh i gotta say i i can't predict um
but there is clearly uh still real
unhappiness amongst many conservative
mps i think it is that loss of trust
that people are finding to say how my
colleagues react uh it is a matter for
their
own judgment and i'm not going to try
and second guess that for them i can
only speak for myself but i think
i'm a pretty mainstream member of the
conservative party
and people can then draw their own
conclusions but what would you like to
say to prime minister boris johnson
tonight now that you've handed in this
letter of no confidence what is your
message to him
that boris had done great service to
this country the biggest service he did
was getting us a majority in 2019 and
seeing off the threat of what i would
regard as a far left and very damaging
uh jeremy corbyn that government and
he's entitled to credit for the work
that he's done in the vaccine's rollout
and is entitled credit
for
the leadership he's shown in pulling the
western democracies together to confront
western
russian aggression in ukraine so he's
done service but sadly
now is the time to hand over the baton
because at the same time he has done
that service unfortunately other actions
have undermined that trust amongst the
electorate and trust in the system and
so it's time now to hand on and let
somebody else take over to rebuild that
trust sir bob neal mp for bromley and
chiselhurst thanks very much indeed
thank you